isn't that what it's all really about  all right we're gonna get a lot of mail  all right you know another thing of  course that today is known for is  Halloween  now many people of course think  Halloween is a very scary time the  studio  I've been hot in the studio city was  built in now I'm going to get you going  I'm gonna get you  no no don't get me I will rip the  feathers of your face and eat them like  they are read rigid eggs I will rip your  red legs off and eat them like they are  giant wizards I will make your red hair  out and easy like it's I don't know  cotton candy or some crap for no Brian  yeah I'll hold you here and after the  show is done I'll haunt you at your  apartment  oh really live on the Upper West Side  right gonna know Brian yeah I live on  the Upper West Side yeah yeah seven days  I think you're not so scary  [Applause]  Oh  he come back  getting back to make him wave thank God  he just slammed into Jesus in the  hallway  [Applause]